Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
show, I am Farron Cousins in for David Pakman
today.
You can find me on YouTube at youtube.com
slash fair and balanced.
You can also find me on the big YouTube channel
youtube.com slash the Ring of Fire.
And of course, I'm on Twitter, Instagram and
Facebook at Ferron Balanced.
So we talked about the good news in the first
segment today, and that may be all the good
news we have, because now it's time to really
get into the nitty gritty, nutty stories of
this week.
And one of those stories we hit on earlier
this week when Donald Trump announced that
he was suing New York's Attorney General Letitia
James because he believes or at least his
lawyer's attempt to argue that the investigation
into him and his company in New York is somehow
unconstitutional.
Yes, unconstitutional to conduct your.
Constitutional duties as investigators, but
that's not it.
That's not all that happened because after
the lawsuit was announced, Donald Trump decided
it would be a sound legal strategy to issue
a statement and openly attack and mock New
York Attorney General Letitia James.
Here is what Donald Trump had to say in his
statement.
And this is a long one.
So bear with me.
Tell Leticia that she is not dealing with
the Cuomo brothers, a corrupt governor and
a corrupt state, including your office and
others, and Fredo who did the governor's dirty
work for him despite many years of investigation
that nobody else could have survived, even
if they did things just slightly wrong.
Yours is just a continuation of the political
witch hunt that is going on against me by
radical left Democrats for years.
This is not about delay.
This is about our constitution.
You are nothing but a corrupt official doing
the dirty work of your party.
You should not be in office.
This could well be the reason you were twice
rejected by the people of New York and your
inept run for governor.
You didn't quit for a higher purpose.
You quit because your poll numbers were atrocious.
You didn't have a chance.
New York got lucky.
Now, I've never been under criminal investigation.
I've never been arrested.
You know, I've never really been on the wrong
side of the law in terms of things like this,
so I don't know.
But I'm willing to bet after working with
the best lawyers in this country for more
than 17 years that openly and repeatedly mocking
and antagonizing the person doing the investigating
are probably not the smartest legal strategy
out there.
I'm just I'm not a lawyer, right?
I didn't go to law school, but I'm willing
to bet that's probably not what you should
do.
And I have to imagine that Trump's lawyers
were sitting there after this statement came
out.
Just probably in shock.
Thinking to themselves, Oh my God, oh lord,
what is going to happen now and then, of course,
probably being happy like, well, wait a minute.
This probably means we get to work a little
bit longer and therefore, you know, we'll
get paid more money.
So, hey, it's a win for us.
But oh my God, this is going to be so difficult
to defend now.
Like, I can't imagine that these lawyers actually
signed off on Trump's attack against the investigator.
This is the woman who holds your fate in her
hand.
You know, I'm willing to bet based on what
we already know from documents that are already
publicly available, that she probably has
enough information to at least charge you
with something right now, whether it sticks
or not is irrelevant, but she could make your
life hell by go ahead, going ahead and filing
charges, at least for what's happening up
in Westchester, right?
We got those docs.
We know what you told the city your property
was worth, and we know what you reported on
your financial disclosure forms as president.
Those two numbers could not be more different.
So I think she could go ahead and probably
pop you for tax fraud right now.
You know, just to kind of get the ball rolling.
And as I discussed the other day, you know
about this whole political witch hunt thing
one, I think he knows something big is about
to happen and he's trying to get ahead of
it.
He's trying to go ahead and plant the seeds
of doubt with his base, with his followers.
So that way, when it finally breaks because
they see, I told you, total political witch
hunt.
But the second thing?
That already disproves the witch hunt theory.
Is that they they found some witches, you
know, Weisselberg has been charged.
The Trump Organization itself has been charged.
OK, those are very real criminal charges against
these two groups.
So you can't sit there and try to say that
all this is all fake.
Nobody listen to it.
Nobody pay attention.
It's absolutely just out to get me for political
purposes.
Well, even if that were true, which it's not
the fact that they found crimes would in fact
justify.
Their political witch hunt, would it not?
But all of this, you know, Trump kind of gave
up the game in a statement like this isn't
about delay.
All right.
So because of that, we now know this is totally
about delay.
And I think the delay that he wants to have
happen is he wants this investigation one
to slow down, and that's what his lawsuit's
about.
So that way after the midterms, assuming Republicans,
when actually it doesn't matter if Republicans
win, but after the midterms, that's when Trump
is likely, according to his closest people,
to announce that he is in fact running for
president again in 2024.
He doesn't want to make this announcement
prior to the midterms because he doesn't want
to be blamed if things go sideways for the
Republicans.
So if the Republicans win, he's going to come
out and say, Listen, you won because of me,
therefore I'm running for president.
If they lose, he's going to say, you lost
because I wasn't there.
Therefore, I am running for president.
Then once he announces he is running for president,
he is going to try to use that, Oh, you can't
prosecute me because I'm a candidate.
I've got executive privilege again, even though
I'm just a candidate.
That's what he's going for.
Wait it out as long as possible.
Try to delay it with this ridiculous lawsuit
filed.
And of course, in the meantime, antagonize
the very people who could ultimately end up
sending you to prison, which again, poor legal
strategy.
But.
It's Trump we're dealing with, so, you know,
you can't hope to control him.
You can only try to contain him every
now and then.